did i hear you right when you just said
that that uh
that that your detached retina that your
eye issues
that you kept secret you said when the
cat was out of the bag
yeah yeah i mean you know so deep into
detail
you know what i mean but but yeah yeah
you know i lost vision in the right eye
so it's a long time ago you could only
see with and you didn't tell anybody
it's crazy
only my uh close only my wife and a very
very couple of close people
you know but uh coaches fortunately
the the legal requirements to fight
you're still
classed as clinically blind so 2200
vision is still classed as clinically
blind
so uh it was a difficult one it was very
stressful because the problem is
uh every fight that you have you know
you do your training camp you fly to
wherever it is you know
i used to fight a lot internationally so
let's say i fly to australia you do an
entire training camp
you fly all your team out there
obviously the training camp is very
expensive
you fly all your team you get the
flights hotels meals
and you got to pay them you know a wage
for coming and then you got to see
a local doctor at the fight the day of
the weigh-in you know what i mean i'm
always like [ __ ]
this guy it might be you know you want
to be that guy
pulls you from the fight you know what
i'm saying takes a look at your eyes
don't [ __ ] this you're not fighting
you shouldn't be fighting so that was
always very stressful because you do all
that work you train your ass off you
spend all that money and the fight might
not happen so that was always really
stressful but
fortunately never happened then i was
able to walk away on my own terms
wow so did you have to sort of trick
them that you had two functioning eyes
for a while
i cannot go into detail i'm sorry
now i mean i think that uh
what what blows me away is that uh
i when i saw you on tmz and and they
they had you on tmz where you actually
took out your eye
and uh and i i i do
not want to ask you to do i'm not asking
you to do it
we did the this show for ufc at one
point called the uf
uh the watch party and and did you ever
see
did you see the episode that we were on
i didn't see it no but funnily enough
i'm doing it again this weekend
how are you they've asked me to do uh uh
a twitch stream
twitch is that for video games yeah and
then instantly i love the ufc there's
nothing i won't do for them
but i'm just concerned about it because
with the watch party you've got like an
actual production crew in your house and
you know they're going to edit it
they're going to put it together it's
going to look great
but with the twitch it's just a constant
stream like you know like the whole you
kind of have to be on the whole time and
i'm just like well what if i just like
trail off and
i'm watching the fights and i'm not like
you know engaged
i'm nervous about not not giving you
doing it right
no i don't know i haven't i haven't uh
decided yes or no
but when we did the watch party thing
and and i haven't seen the episode
either
you did take out your eye for me and
it's
so fascinating to me that uh i don't
know if they included that in the
episode or not no no i was just thinking
you're right i did i totally forgot all
about that
obviously i uh you don't drink anymore
steve all but my boxing coach does
and and i don't see him very often and i
don't drink that much these days either
contrary to popular belief
everybody thinks i'm this crazy party
animal i'm i'm really not i mean when i
was younger i was a [ __ ] nightmare
but these days i'm pretty good i'm 42
yesterday uh so but jason parillo came
up and i don't get to see him in a
social function very often
and the ufc they brought drinks and
brunch and food and
you know it's a watch party it's a
saturday morning i've got no work so i
had a few drinks
so i was like hold on did i i'm like oh
yeah
it's so fascinating to me that you've
got an artificial
eye it's completely [ __ ] fake
but you you control it like uh yeah
did when did this technology become a
thing i mean
tell me about it because i you know if i
don't have it in my eye looks terrible
it looks a mess and you know i'm i'm
working on an acting career i'm very
lucky
you know i'm landing a few roles here
and there but obviously nobody wants
a [ __ ] actor with a [ __ ] up eye
looking like a cyclops or a [ __ ]
something from a horror movie unless the
character is written like that you know
what i'm saying so i'm going for all
these auditions
and i was always so [ __ ]
self-conscious you know what i mean
that's all i was trying to do hide my
eye stand a certain way or whatever
so i got to see these opticians and
they're these specialized lenses
that had like a fake eyeball but it was
off-centered so you put it in and it
kind of looks real
but then after a while what it would do
was drift to the center and it would
look even worse
so when i'd work at fox sports all the
time i had like a little compact a
little makeup compact
and anytime we cut to b-roll or
commercial break i'd have to always pull
it out
and re-center it all the time that was
my life and
i was going up to this uh this opticians
it was like a two-hour drive away from
me i had to go there every six weeks it
was a [ __ ] pain in the ass
and then eventually i thought to myself
i'm over this i'm just gonna get a glass
eye i'm gonna have it removed and have a
glass
eye so i made an appointment with a
doctor here in orange county
and she looked at me and she said you
don't need you know we don't want to
operate
that's always the last resort she said
there's a doctor close by
uh that can do these prosthetic lenses
turns out this place that makes them
five minutes from my house right and
they hand paint it
and match it perfectly they do a
fantastic job and uh
yeah the best three thousand dollars i
ever spent in my life
and then yeah that's what she said that
day three thousand bucks
and uh it's just not the way that you
picture it either like uh
when you take it out it's it's like uh
yeah dude is he doing it
yeah oh wow absolutely
unbelievable i didn't want to ask you to
do that much yeah you're good i mean
the only reason i did it once on my
podcast hold on
believe you me podcast yeah that's right
i did it on there
the guy i do it with my co-host he
turned up and he's wearing sunglasses in
door while we're doing the show so i'm
bitching at him a little bit i'm making
fun of him i hear the [ __ ]
look at this rock star you know what i
mean and he starts talking [ __ ] to me
hold on a minute
i've seen you showing up at press
conferences with sunglasses on and i
said yes
you're right but the reason i always
used to wear sunglasses
was because of the eye because i didn't
want some jumped up [ __ ] commission
members saying hey
come over here let me take a look at
your eye or somebody from the ufc or
whatever you know what i'm saying
by putting sunglasses on no one could
see [ __ ] so with the guy who's making
fun out
for fun out of me saying oh you used to
wear sunglasses indoor i'm like okay
this is why i used to wear [ __ ]
sunglasses so that's how that came out
and that's how
the whole thing and then of course you
know you got tmz in places like that
picking it up so
yeah the cat's out of the bag it is what
it is that's crazy
like it's just sure let me return the
favor
i got i pull out my teeth quite easily
thank you so much for watching this clip
and guess what
i have the number 30 ranked hot sauce on
all of
amazon it's called stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole
yeah yeah
dude